cited against julian
on this occasion
on the basis of political
uh assurances non-assurances
that the u.s has given to the uk
government
i say non-assurances
amnesty international says
non-assurances amnesty international has
analyzed these assurances and have said
that they are inherently unreliable
they incorporate the possibility of
breaking those assurances in their very
wording
today
it's been almost a year since i stood
outside court
with our victory of the blocking of the
extradition for the past year and the
past year two years and a half
julian has remained in belmar's prison
and in fact
he has been detained
since the 7th of december 2010 in one
form or another 11 years for how long
can this go on
today is international human rights day
what a shame how cynical
to have this decision on this day
to have
one of the foremost the foremost
publisher
journalist
of the past
50 years
in a uk prison
accused of publishing the truth
about
war crimes about cia kill teams and in
fact every time we have
a hearing
more we know more about
the abusive nature
the criminal nature of this case
julian exposed the crimes of cia
torturers of cia killers
and now we know that those c i a killers
were planning to kill him too
how can this court
how can these courts
approve an extradition request
under these conditions
how can they
accept
an extradition to the country that
plotted to kill julian that plotted to
kill a publisher because of what he
published
this goes to the fundamentals of press
freedom and of democracy
we will fight
every generation has an epic fight to
fight and this is ours because julian
represents the fundamentals of what it
means to live in a free society of what
it means to have press freedom
of what it means for journalists to do
their jobs without being afraid of
spending the rest of their lives in
prison
the uk imprisons journalists
they're imprisoning julian
on behalf of a foreign power which is
taking an abusive
vindictive prosecution against a
journalist and this is what it's about
i urge everyone to come together and
fight for julian
julian represents all our liberties and
all our rights
thank you
well sir
[Music]